you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
disruption in westminster as climate
protesters block streets in the second
day of demonstrations
confirmation from scientists that
climate change did make last month's
deadly floods in europe more likely
and the nature inspired green materials
being used in climate-friendly batteries
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show now it's day two of
climate protests by extinction rebellion
with activists blocking roads around
parliament square and targeting the hmrc
building in westminster
protesters want the government to
immediately end all investment in fossil
fuels but are the demonstrations likely
to make a difference to government
policy or turn people away from the
cause altogether our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter
reports
extinction rebellion protesters in
central london
racing to block whitehall
or part of a two-week plan to disrupt
the capital
today the target is the treasury and
government funding of the fossil fuel
industry it's not just about the
dividend at the end of the year it's
about making sure that there is an end
of the year and the next year and our
children have got a future to look
forward to it's one thing buying organic
food from the health food shop on the
corner what difference does it make if
your money is going into the fossil fuel
industry
the police have warned that this kind of
disruption is pulling them away from
communities in need the mayor of london
has said that he supports the right to
democratic and peaceful protest and that
climate change is something that needs
tackling with increasing urgency but
he's also warned that disruptive actions
that break the law will only be
counterproductive to the course
these protesters don't agree are you
potentially overshadowing your message
by causing so much disruption i think
that the disruption currently caused by
forest fires and floods are already
causing more disruption than this this
is tiny this is negligible really i know
that we're causing a lot of disruption i
really know that
but the disruption that if we don't do
something it's just going to be such
it's going to be catastrophic the whole
planet's in crisis and i just feel like
the time is really running out
although in terms of sheer numbers
extinction rebellion isn't the force it
once was it is still a determined one
however unlikely it is to shift
government policy or the behavior of big
business it has many more plans to stop
business as usual in the nation's
capital hannah thomas peter sky news
climate change made the catastrophic
floods in europe last month up to nine
times more likely that's according to
rapid analysis by an international group
of scientists parts of germany belgium
the netherlands and luxembourg were
devastated after rain caused severe
flooding back in july more than 200
people lost their lives and homes
businesses and infrastructure were all
destroyed well the world weather
attribution group carried out the
analysis of the floods and found the
extreme rainfall events that caused them
are now between 1.2 and 9 times more
likely to happen because of global
warming and you can see here how the
extreme rain swept across western europe
it started in england on july the 11th
before moving across france and belgium
and reaching germany by the 13th of july
now by analyzing weather records and
using computer simulations scientists
found that downpours like this are now
between 3 and 19
heavier in the region than when the
world was 1.2 degrees cooler and that
1.2 degree number is important because
it's how much our planet has warmed
since the industrial revolution and you
can see here on our data dashboard how
global warming is ticking up the whole
time making extreme weather events more
likely as well as more severe
well one of the lead authors of that
report is dr sarah q a climate scientist
from the royal netherlands
meteorological institute so welcome to
you
your study then showed that climate
change did make the extreme rainfall
that we saw more likely but there was a
big range in that likelihood wasn't
there between 1.2 times and nine times
more likely why the breadth of that
range
yeah that's right and so our results
highlight that at the local river
catchment scale that the detection of
trends and extreme rainfall is hindered
by the large day-to-day and year-to-year
variability in the rainfall data
but when we considered similar events
occurring over a larger western european
uh western european region so between
the north and northern side of the alps
and the netherlands we found that uh
significant trends due to human-induced
climate change then became evident
so what
uh yeah the results um therefore show
that there's a relation with climate
change and that's the most important
conclusion but we need more research
more model data and more high resolution
models to be able to reduce the
uncertainty range
and factor one point there actually
means there's already been a 20
increase in frequency of these kinds of
events which is really important for
impacts
well yes and what can be done to reduce
the likelihood of this sort of event in
the future then
well there have always been extreme
weather events that occur now and again
so that will also be the case in the
future however we see that climate
change is making extreme events like
these more frequent and more intense and
the best thing to do about this is to
rapidly reduce those greenhouse gas
emissions
but we need to be aware that greenhouse
gases will stay in the atmosphere for
hundreds of years so in our lifetimes it
will be a matter of not exacerbating the
climate change any further rather than
being able to strongly reduce it
but adaptation will also help to reduce
the impact of extreme weather on
people's lives and also on the
infrastructure their livelihoods so it's
important for water boards and
authorities for example to know what we
can expect in the future
and dikes can be reinforced or flood
buffer zones created in the locations
where that is possible
also warning systems are obviously very
high importance and reaching out to our
vulnerable neighbours
dr sarah q thanks very much indeed
thank you
well in today's other climate news more
than 13 000 firefighters are attempting
to contain a dozen large wildfires that
have destroyed hundreds of buildings and
forced people to evacuate their homes in
california hot and dry conditions made
worse by climate change have caused the
fires to spread rapidly scientists are
warning that wildfires will become more
frequent as global warming intensifies
development work at the site of the
proposed cambo oil field has been
delayed until next year it comes after
greenpeace claimed that work was
starting early before permits had been
issued sicar point energy said
operational issues were behind the delay
the government's been criticized for
letting plans for the site in the north
sea go ahead despite hosting the cop 26
climate summit in november
a demonstration flight of what could be
the uk's first electric commuter plane
successfully took off from exeter today
the flight which ended at cornwall's new
key airport is the start of low carbon
test flights between the two counties if
the trials are successful hybrid
electric planes which produce 70 fewer
emissions than traditional aircraft
could become a more common sight in uk
skies
now here on the daily climate show we do
love to feature people coming up with
solutions to the climate crisis and one
of those is professor magda titus
who's just won a royal society award for
her work on sustainable energy storage
well i'll be speaking to her in just a
moment but first let's take a look at
what she's been working on
[Music]
and professor magda titurichi from
imperial college london joins me now
first of all many congratulations on
your award and first of all let me ask
you about the area of your work that
focuses on lignin as an alternative to
lithium for use in batteries like
electric car batteries
tell us what lignum is and why we need
an alternative to lithium
yeah so lignin is one of the components
in any plants
along with cellulose and hemi cellulose
for example when we're using plants to
make paper
uh we are after the cellulosic fraction
as well as when we want to make biofuels
from from biomass and lignin is the one
the fraction that nobody wants they is
normally of no use and we found the
solution and we take this lignin which
is actually responsible of giving uh
good strength and mechanical properties
to plant and taking inspiration from
nature a little bit like the spider
spice the web we spy we spin this lignin
into fibers which you can make
conductive and a good mechanical
properties and we can use this as
electrodes in pretty much any battery
whether it's a lithium or sodium battery
and so it can be either the anode which
is the negative electrode but it could
also be on both sides for for particular
uh battery applications and instead of
lithium we are then using some metallic
sodium clusters and we can produce
batteries with an energy density that is
higher than what lithium ions have today
so how much greener is the production
then of lignin and how easy and cost
effective might it be to get it to
market
so the lignin production is quite easy
because we are doing this since we've
discovered paper this is produced in in
huge amounts of megatons a year in all
the paper and plants industry and and
now in all the biorefineries and so it's
a widely available uh resources
and it's almost available at no cost
again to produce the materials from
lignin you use relatively low energy
input low temperatures in particular we
figure out that the lower the
temperature that we use the better the
performance of this material is
so it is uh obviously most
cost-effective than uh lithium-ion
battery today which relies on critical
materials that are mined somewhere else
rather than in the uk
fascinating stuff uh professor magda
titarichi thanks very much indeed
okay
and finally sydney has announced dark
roofs will be banned on new homes in an
effort to combat climate change in
australia lighter colored surfaces
retain less heat resulting in less
electricity being used to cool down
buildings the new rules also mean that
every garden will be required to have a
tree to provide shade and absorb carbon
dioxide
and that's everything from us for today
tomorrow find out why climate change
could mean uk summer holidays are under
threat thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]